how big is this I mean this is a is this
considered excessive even by Silicon
Valley I'm like Ed McMahon I was
supposed to how big is it Johnny so it
is so big it's 70 million dollars is her
pay package over a couple of years but
we've seen a couple of CFOs coming to
Silicon Valley and command some massive
pay now
the annual base is 650,000 that's very
interesting
because that's exactly what all of the
top executives including Google's top
lawyer makes his base salary but the
restricted stock of 25 million the stock
grants of 40 million and the sinon
business is five million dollars this is
this is big money even by Silicon Valley
standards and certainly by Wall Street
standards and it's and again it is stock
so we don't know what the ultimate value
is going to be but those are the prices
kind of put on it at this point you know
I gotta say you know Wall Street when
people in Wall Street the CEO is the
CFO's make a lot of money people cry you
know they're thieves they're you know
using villainize villainized exactly
thank you but on Silicon Valley often by
people from Silicon Valley right but
they're I mean it's sort of viewed as
the Promised Land the place of
innovation and there really doesn't seem
to be this kind of feeling about these
big pay packages do you see that
changing you saw a lot of its in stock
and so and there's a sense that that's
the best practice to align it with the
interest of shareholders and these are
straight stock grants so unlike the case
of say Meg Whitman at eBay we're a
quarter of her pay packages based on a
non-gaap earnings after restructuring
costs is sort of creating an incentive
to keep the restructuring going on
forever keep putting an incentive I'm
doing layoffs and things these are pure
stock grants or pure stock option grants
so in that sense and they're also you
know in the case of others such as
Anthony Noto's a big pay package to
Twitter it vests over the course of many
years you got to be in it to win it
you've got to stay there and get the
stock over time and deliver longer term
results so from that from that
perspective at least they are aligned
with the interests of the shareholders
over the longer term without funkiness
getting involved
non-gaap earnings and and an unaligned
benefits there I also think that when
you look at some of these pay packages
you know you're talking about people who
are expected to perform at the very top
level of any company Google is one of
the biggest companies in the world
facing some of the biggest challenges
and growing they hope as fast as any
business will now if you compare them
across the board
you know let's look at Anthony notas pay
package and we look at what he got to go
for Twitter where he has been for less
than a year so we haven't seen what the
actual valuation being put on the stock
is but when you add up all the different
elements of this pay package and I think
we have a full screen to that effect we
can see that the guy makes a ton of
money but again a lot of that was in
stock a lot of that was in stock granted
to him
on the day that he joined and signed his
offer letter what kind of challenges
does this near-monopoly face how is it
so hard for for Google well yeah those
compared some other people right so
Google has its challenges they own the
internet so what what's troubling them
they're trying to go from yes we're
moment to cry for Google well it's an
interesting business avoid some big
changes right their businesses dot being
dominant inserts on the computer well
guess what people compute here now and
so they're trying to make that change
happen so they've created this dramatic
business with Android where they're
giving the software way hoping to direct
business back to themselves in search
hoping to grow into other business but
according to the FTC staff report an
investigation by the EU maybe they're
doing that illegally by using the
monopoly power in search to build new
businesses to compare that to the
challenges at Yahoo right Ken Goldman
chief financial officer at Yahoo is paid
significantly less and here's a guy
who's got to figure out how to save this
businesses total comp of six million
salary of six hundred thousand
restricted stock of 2.6 million and
long-term comp also 2.6 million but when
you look out of this paper this is a guy
who had to figure out how to sell this
Alibaba asset not keep the working in
the partnership with the government
where they had to pay enormous taxes and
gains who he's got to figure out to
monetize their Softbank Yahoo
relationship in Yahoo Japan who's got to
revive this business from the dead I'm
sure he's looking at the pay package at
Google thinking hey Marissa protectors
yeah I thought Yahoo
I thought Yahoo directors get over a
hundred million dollars and only had to
stay for like nine months isn't that
what normal yo-yo is told in the CFO who
has at least as much heavy lifting to
may have be left holding back this